Arguing about the nature of the country
is as American as frozen apple pie
with a slice of processed cheese,
says the aspirationally
acute, 80-year-old,
Pulitzer Prize winner, George Will.
Now in his sixth decade as a leading voice
in debates over culture,
politics and ideas.
If you don't like arguing, he says,
you picked the wrong country.
Will's newest book is American
Happiness and Discontents,
a collection of columns
called from 2008 to 2020.
They cover the Great
Recession and the Obama years,
to what he calls the cry-baby
presidency of Donald J. Trump,
and the rise of identity politics
as a major force in contemporary America.
Though he started out firmly
on the conservative right,
Will has become more and more libertarian,
especially in his insistence
that mere politics should never be
the all-consuming passion
of human endeavor,
and that America remains a place
dedicated to a future that
is better than the present.
If we can reign in our appetite
for government to dispense
benefits, he says,
and replace it with a government
that defends the shores,
fills the potholes, and
otherwise gets out of the way,
we're gonna see, again,
the creativity of the American people.
Here is the recent
interview with George Will.
George Will, thanks for talking to Reason.
Glad to be with you.
So, your new book,
American Happiness and
Discontents: The Unruly Torrent,
collects your columns from 2008 to 2020.
Let's talk about this concept
of the unruly torrent.
What do you mean by that?
And why is that a kind
of controlling image
for this passel of, you know,
interesting columns that you've collected?
Well, it's unruly in the
sense that it is a torrent.
That is, it is, we are, most
of reality is not governed.
Most of the time that's a very good thing.
It's been well said that
the essence of the Bible
reduced to one sentence
says God created man and woman
and promptly lost control of events.
Those of us with libertarian streak,
some streaks broader than
others, but mine is broad enough,
believe that things being out of control
is exactly what we want.
Right.
We want a spontaneous order,
up from the bottom creativity
rather than down from the
top command structures.
However, events can be unruly,
and turbulent, and dangerous,
as well as constructive ways.
And I think we're seeing
the dangerous side
in the last, in that
period that my book covers.
Before we get to the dangerous
side and the discontent,
let's talk about the title,
you know, American Happiness.
What, you know, what
over the past 15 years
do Americans have to be happy about,
that either we aren't quite celebrating
or we just kind of take for granted?
Well, first of all,
we're speaking shortly after
the 20th anniversary of 9/11,
and we can be happy
that there's been no other
mass casualty terrorist attack,
not for want of trying on
the part of the terrorist.
Terrorist attacks that are preempted
or forestalled in other ways
don't get noticed by definition,
and therefore we tend not to credit those
who are in the business
of preventing them.
I have a son who's an FBI
Agent in Counter Terrorism
so I'm a little sensitive to
this non-allocation of credit.
But, so there is that.
Second, the American economy
continues to whir along
in spite of the government's
best attempts to stop it.
Third, we've just gone through a pandemic
in which Big Pharma, the
villain du jour most days,
Big Pharma stepped up
and with amazing dispatch
produced several vaccines
that are safe, reliable,
effective, and free essentially.
So, we have that to...
the basic creativity
of the Western society
showed itself here.
Do you think there is something inherent,
and I, you know, I reject as you do,
a kind of blood and
soil national identity,
particularly when it's related to America.
But is there something in the American DNA
where we cannot stay happy?
You know, there's that
great scene in Key Largo,
the Humphrey Bogart,
Edward G. Robinson movie,
where at one point, Rocky,
the, you know, the bad guy
played by Edward G. Robinson,
is asked, like, what do you want?
And he says, I want more, I want more.
Is there, you know, is there
something about America
where some of the things
that you just rattled off,
you know, it's like, yeah,
okay, but what else do you have?
Why, you know, it seems
as if among, you know,
many of our insatiable appetites
is we're never very happy for very long.
Yeah. That's what it's called.
Someone called it the
joyless pursuit of joy.
I'll match your pop
culture with one of my own.
And, by the way, I wanna point out
that a reference to Key
Largo, pop culture is,
I think that might be ancient
history by now. But, please.